ein schwarzer tag für thüringen ein
dammbruch
darin sind sich alle parteien auf
bundesebene außer der afg einig zum
ersten mal wurde ein ministerpräsident
mit stimmen der afg ins amt gewählt er
heißt thomas kemmerich und kommt von der
fdp dem amtsinhaber bodo ramelow von der
linken vierte genau eine stimme die afg
mit ihrem fraktionsvorsitzenden höcke
triumphiert und 70 in der bürgerlichen
mitte angekommen
eine zusammenarbeit mit der afg
schließen alle parteien aus cdu/csu
fordern neuwahl
paukenschlag in thüringen folgen für
berlin unser thema in der frühlings
runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend aus berlin ich darf
meine gäste vorstellen von der linken
ist bei uns bernd riexinger 2012 ist er
einer der beiden vorsitzenden der partei
die linke von der cdu ruprecht polenz
ehemaliger generalsekretär seiner partei
und von 1994 bis 2013 mitglied des
bundestages für die spd ist hier lothar
binding seit 1998 auch im bundestag
finanzpolitischer sprecher der fraktion
er gehört zur parlamentarischen linken
seiner partei von der afg begrüße ich
georg pastörs ging erst seit 2016
mitglied des abgeordnetenhauses in
berlin landesvorsitzender und bis 2019
waren sie auch einer der
stellvertretenden bundessprecher und als
beobachterinnen begrüße ich ganz
herzlich ulrike herrmann von der taz ja
das war eine überraschung heute in
thüringen jetzt ist thomas kemmerich
gewählt herr polenz was bedeutet das für
die cdu ist ein ganz schlimmes ergebnis
ein ganz schlechter tag und die cdu
hätte es nie soweit kommen lassen dürfen
es war klar dass bei einer geheimen wahl
das risiko bestand dass die afg ihren
eigenen kandidaten nicht wählen würde
und damit hatte die cdu eigentlich nur
noch zwei optionen entweder sich
geschlossen der stimme zu enthalten oder
mit einem eigenen kandidaten anzutreten
sie hatte also in gewisser weise schon
mit schuld dass das jetzt so passiert
ist
die fdp hat auch sehenden auges mit
feuer gespielt und mit einem eigenen
kandidaten ein was weiß ich welches
signal senden wollen
und aus dieser situation kann man jetzt
nur noch raus kommen indem möglichst
schnell der weg zu neuwahlen frei
gemacht wird ob das über einen rücktritt
des jetzt gerade gewählten neuen
ministerpräsidenten geht und über
welchen weg auch immer es müssen jetzt
die wählerinnen und wähler die
möglichkeit haben die thüringer
verhältnisse wieder in ordnung zu
bringen
eric singer ihr kandidat bodo ramelow
hat verloren ganz knapp er hatte eine
hohe zustimmung in der bevölkerung
eigentlich was haben was war das
versichern nachmittag
ja ich war geschockt ich weiß im übrigen
ausnahmen gesprächen mit bodo ramelow
das ja auch geschockt ist und das
erstmal verdauen muss man muss sich
einmal vorstellen da ist jemand da der
kriegt über 30 prozent stärkste partei
einer der beliebtesten
ministerpräsidenten
und dann wird durch trickserei und
betrügerei jemand gewählt der gerade mal
fünf prozent der stimmen auf sich
vereinigt ich finde das ist wirklich
nett trickserei und auch ein betrug an
den wählern und wählerinnen den ganz
anderen willen geäußert haben
es ist aber auch in hohem maße
dramatisch weil hier fdp und cdu sich
als steigbügelhalter für die afg
hergegeben haben
im prinzip hat die afg zum ersten mal
von ihren gnaden einen
ministerpräsidenten ins amt gebracht ich
glaube das wird weitreichende folgen
haben und muss in der tat dringend
korrigiert werden
ich habe nicht nur wein ich habe nicht
gewusst dass wir es mit solchen hass
saturn zu tun haben
die mit solchen taschenspielertricks
arbeiten aber ich glaube auch dass
dringend neuwahlen erforderlich sind
herr pastewka die afg hatten eigenen
kandidaten aufgestellt im zweiten
wahlgang wurde der auch gewählt dann im
dritten wahlgang keine stimmen mehr der
afg warum haben sie ihren eigenen
kandidaten nicht gewählt
das ist doch klar es musste die
regierung ramelow abgeholt abgewählt
werden wenn man sich auch die
mehrheitsverhältnisse sind thüringen
anschaut dann ist auch links grün ist
abgewählt worden und was heute im
landtag passiert ist man eigentlich eine
logische folge des wählerwillens und ich
kann auch diese ganze aufregung nicht
verstehen
ich kann den herrn nur zurufen
willkommen in der demokratie so sieht
das aus in einer demokratie wird gewählt
demokratisch gewählt daher zählen
mehrheiten und das ist heute passiert in
thüringen kommt es nicht komisch an
meinem wähler wenn dann der der eigene
kandidat nicht gewählt wird von wenn
wände von der afg keine einzige stimme
dem eigenen kandidaten geben wird ja
aber der punkt ist doch es geht darum
was ist das beste für das land und was
ist das beste für thüringen und
offensichtlich ist für thüringen eine
bürgerliche koalition oder zumindestens
ein bürgerliches bündnis ist wichtiger
als beispielsweise den eigenen
kandidaten zu wählen denn wir haben
gesehen dass herr ramelow in den letzten
fünf jahren so gut wie nichts erreicht
hat in thüringen und es ist eigentlich
eine bankrotterklärung auch der anderen
parteien wenn sie jetzt darüber
herziehen und neuwahlen fordern
wie lange wollen wir den wellen nur so
lange wählen bis die koalition passen
bis die mehrheiten so zustande gekommen
sind wie man sie braucht also ich kann
nur ich kann nur den kopf schütteln über
das demokratieverständnis dieser leute
die hier ständig von tabubruch reden von
schwarzer tag für die demokratie ist ein
hervorragender tag für die demokratie
verbinden wie sehen sie es gibt eine
einladung von dem neuen
ministerpräsidenten kemmerich der sagt
lasst uns mit der spd zusammenarbeiten
ist das eine möglichkeit für sie habe es
sind völlig unehrliches angebot denn die
spd die grünen die linke haben ja zuvor
einen sehr offenen koalitionsvertrag
gemacht haben dass fdp und cdu angeboten
haben gesagt lasst uns von den
demokraten eine gemeinsame
regierungsverantwortung übernehmen das
wurde aber wie ich inzwischen weist
taktisch von cdu und fdp abgelehnt und
jeder der jetzt sagt das war ein
überraschendes ergebnis oder die
bürgerlichen hätten damit rechnen müssen
er weiß genau dass ist natürlich gelogen
und das erkennt man ganz deutlich daran
hat in der demokratie ist doch absurd
dass ich jemanden vorschlage ich schlage
jemanden vor wie man zu wählen und dann
wähle ich ihn selber nicht was ist das
ja ein unehrlicher vorschlag also das
eben genau nicht demokratisch und dann
kommt auch nicht in der demokratischen
mitte an in dem man sich in der
demokratie bewegt sondern nach einer
wahl kommt darauf an eine demokratische
politik zu machen für ein ganzes land
und das ist sie hoch gefährdet wer
einmal höher gehört der versteht das
sofort woher man also ein besonderer tag
historischer tag zum ersten mal eben mit
stimmen der fdp an ministerpräsident
gewählt wird die reaktionen sind
wirklich enorm was bedeutet das denn
jetzt hier für berlin
na ja also es bedeutet ja vor allen
dingen dass man gesehen hat in thüringen
dass die cdu in einer wirklich
schwierigen lage ist denn also rein
strategisch mal gesehen auf der einen
seite will sie sich gegenüber der afg
abgrenzen
auf der anderen seite
hätte ja eine zusammenarbeit mit den
linken bedeutet und morin weiter für ja
anfangs sogar offen dass sie wähler an
die fdp verloren hätten weitere wähler
also und das ist sozusagen das
prinzipielle problem für die cdu wie
soll man mit der afg umgehen ohne dass
man wähle an sie verliert und herr
polenz hat alles gesagt was man dazu
sagen kann also was die cdu in thüringen
falsch gemacht hat und ich glaube dass
die bundes-cdu unbedingt darauf achten
muss dass tatsächlich diese grenze
zwischen cdu und fdp stehen bleibt weil
sonst ist die cdu wahrscheinlich
rettungslos verloren
bevor wir über die cdu und die anderen
parteien und weiterreden hören wir uns
doch mal kurz den neuen
ministerpräsidenten an wir haben
übrigens auch jemanden versucht von der
fdp zu bekommen das ist in der kürze der
zeit hat das nicht geklappt wir haben ja
die sendung kurzfristig ins programm
genommen wir wollen aber jetzt mal dem
neuen ministerpräsidenten bodo kemmerich
von der fdp hören wie er sich nach
seiner wahl am nachmittag in einer
pressekonferenz geäußert hatte es war
eine geheime wahl unter drei kandidaten
ist die fdp agiert hat wie reagiert hat
können sie selber bewerten ich kann nur
nochmals betonen die brandmauern
gegenüber die afd bleiben bestehen mit
einem ministerpräsidenten kemmerich wird
es kein angebot keine koalition keine
miss ministerien und auch keine afd
politik geben was wir vor der wahl
gesagt haben dass wir mit den extremen
aus beiden politischen lagern nicht
zusammenarbeit bleibt auch nach der wahl
bestehen auch am heutigen tage und auch
die für die zeit mailand der
ministerpräsident der neue aus thüringen
wird noch etwas nervös und noch
wahrscheinlich auch noch sehr
überraschte weiß man ja auch verstehen
kann er passte was haben sie gewonnen
wenn alle sagen wir wollen auf keinen
fall mit derartig zusammenarbeiten die
bekommen keine ministerium die können
nicht mitregieren regieren was haben sie
gewonnen
es geht doch nicht darum dass wir
ministerien haben wollen
es geht doch darum dass wir für
thüringen die beste politik machen und
wissen sie gerne arbeiten also der punkt
ist doch wir sind in deutschland nicht
gewöhnt dass beispielsweise
minderheitsregierung toleriert werden in
skandinavien ist das gang und gäbe
so also wenn der herr kemmerich schlau
ist wird er sich die mehrheiten suchen
die er für seine politik braucht und ich
gehe mal davon aus dass wir da tun und
es geht doch nicht um parteien es geht
doch nicht darum dass ich irgendwelche
ministerium besetzt sondern es geht auch
darum dass sich politik für thüringen
machen dass sich politik für den bürger
machen wir dürfen ja an sich vergessen
fast jeder vierte thüringer wähler hat
afg gewählt und was man jetzt tut ist
man versucht jetzt ein viertel der
wähler in thüringen versucht man
auszukennen sie nach dem motto mit denen
wollen wir gar nichts zu tun haben was
ist das für ein demokratisches
verständnis was ist das für eine
auffassung also wenn sich diese parteien
demokratisch impfen kann ich nur kann
ich nur sagen dann sollten sie wirklich
mal in sich gehen sollten überlegen
überlegen ob das wirklich ein
demokratisches verhalten ist herr polenz
was würden sie sagen wie was ist kann
das funktionieren dass man die afg
ausgrenzt dass es keine neuwahlen gibt
nach dem was würdest du auch der cdu
landesverband thüringen er ist nicht für
neuwahlen
wenn man weiter mit dem
ministerpräsidenten kemmerich arbeiten
will dann muss man ja irgendwie
mehrheiten bekommen und wenn sie das
geht überhaupt nicht also wenn wir hier
über minderheitsregierung und
skandinavien und zu reden dann müssen
wir doch den unterschied festhalten
in skandinavien lässt sich keine
regierung von der faschistischen partei
tolerieren und das wird auch in
deutschland nicht geben und das muss man
auch mal klar benennen die afd ist eine
faschistische partei und mit der
jähriges mädchen so ganz ehrlich sagen
mit der gibt es keinerlei zusammenarbeit
das ist die ausgangsbasis für alle
weiteren überlegungen und die cdu hat
natürlich eine schwierige aufgabe in
knappen verhältnissen in thüringen jetzt
eigene position zu finden aber sie ist
eben auch nicht nur thüringen sondern
ganz deutschland gegenüber verpflichtet
und das was wir heute in den
schlagzeilen zu dammbruch und so weiter
gelesen haben muss ja auch in erfurt und
in thüringen bei meinen parteifreunden
die glocken klingeln lassen
und da geht es jetzt nicht nur darum wie
geht es in thüringen weiter sondern geht
es darum ob die cdu allen menschen in
deutschland klar machen kann dass wenn
jemand meine partei wählt er völlig
sicher sein kann dass es keinerlei
zusammenarbeit mit der ard gibt das ist
jetzt die aufgabe von der meine partei
steht ja er hatte aber mehr stimmen
jetzt 23 4 prozent der stimmen gehabt
und die cdu 21 jahren das ist ein
wichtiger punkt die grenzen auch nicht
afd wähler aus sondern wir grenzen die
faschistische partei afd aus um die
wähler werben wir der ebenfalls in sed
wir haben der die cdu in thüringen hat
gespräche geführt mit dem
ministerpräsidenten dieses landes
und da ist ausgelotet worden wie man mit
den mehr als mit den schwierigen
verhältnissen umgehen kann ist aber ein
anderes thema jetzt bleiben bei dem was
jetzt auf der auf der tagesordnung steht
und das heißt wenn hiervon brandmauern
geräte wird auch von der fdp dann frage
ich mich warum man da vorher vor diese
band mauer leicht entzündliches material
gelegt hat also das hätte ja nicht
passieren
als auch warum den wirklichen sitzt ja
wenn man kemmerich hat das ja auch klar
gesagt keiner zusammen heute nach rechts
und nach links wie empfinden sie das
wenn das wenn sie gleich gesetzt werden
da wenn es die gleichsetzung zwischen
afd und liegen ja das war völlig absurd
also natürlich wissen neue lehr ist eine
neue linke partei die fdp wolle ramelow
hat dort einer völlig demokratische
politik gemacht ja er wurde von der
mehrheit der bürger und bürgerinnen
thüringen wäre sogar direkt gewählt
worden
wir sind die stärkste partei dort
geworden und was haben sie gemacht haben
was für die kitas gemacht haben die
kommunen besser ausgerüstet sie haben
mehr lehrer eingestellt und sogar mehr
polizisten eingestellt also eine in sich
gute politik mit der auch die mehrheit
der bevölkerung zufrieden war und die
war transparent was die afd jetzt
gemacht hat landet billige trickserei
und was heute von sich äußert ist
natürlich rechtsradikales und zum teil
neon hat
hessisches zeugs mit solchen parteien
kann man nicht zusammen arbeiten und ich
bin auch etwas entsetzt über die
stellungnahmen der fdp
als ich mein wenn kubicki gezeigt das
wäre großartig dass hier jemand aus der
mitte gewählt wurde
dann frage ich mich was ihr dem ins glas
getan haben
der chef gesagt hat also lindner hat
direkte das darf keine zusammenarbeit
aber es war auch keine so ganz deutliche
äußerung er hat sich ein bisschen
versteckt dass das eine sache der
thüringer landespartei ist ich meine das
ist so ein gravierender tabubruch das
ist nicht mehr sache einer einzelnen
landes partei deshalb auch
bundespolitische folgen die wähler und
wählerinnen wissen nicht mehr wenn sie
fdp oder cdu wählen können wir sicher
sein dass die keine allianz meter afd
eingehen und das muss jetzt die
bundesebene richten
das kann man nicht einfach so stehen
und was heißt das für die große
koalition ein herr binding ihre paar
neue parteichefin saskia esken die hat
sich geäußert die hat gesagt wenn wir
haben dringende fragen an die cdu müssen
wollen das auch ganz glücklich in einem
koalitionsausschuss klären also muss man
das auch die bundesebene bringen ist oft
die ebene der bundesregierung ich glaube
es ist klug sich damit zu befassen weil
die cdu ist ja für uns erst mal ein
großes ganzes sondern wir sehen da gibt
es probleme innerhalb der cdu ist es
klug wenn man darüber redet nach meinem
ersten eindruck aber hat ja kramp
karrenbauer sich sehr klar von diesen
verhältnissen in thüringen distanziert
also das ist für mich eine gute
verhandlungsbasis ist also deshalb
glaube ich dass es wird den bund im
negativen zunächst nicht erreichen also
das denke ich dass wir da auf der
sicheren seite sind nach den klaren
worten von kramp karrenbauer und wir
haben auch klare worte formuliert dass
die spd da keinerlei
kooperationsmöglichkeiten in thüringen
sieht mit jemand der von der afg gewählt
wurde ist völlig klar weil eben für uns
auch klar ist dass nicht die wähler die
faschisten sind sondern das sind eben
die funktionäre und das kann man sehr
stark nachlesen über judentum gesprochen
wird über den vogel schießt der
geschichte wenn ihr es gibt ganz viele
dinge die sind diskriminierend
claudia razzia kaspersky sie müssen sich
auch klar machen ich habe in wikipedia
gelesen dass sie schon mal illegal
landesvorsitzender waren dass sie
angetreten sondern ein unsinn was das
ist feindliches nicht so dumm angeredet
heute über thüringen das ja auch immer
werden die retourpartie wird wir reden
aber türen hat ein landes- und
fraktionsvorsitzende
wir wären sehr umstritten ist der
natürlich den mann offiziell nazi nennen
darf und von dem sie sich auch immer
wieder distanziert haben wo sie klar
gesagt um das ist der flügel den in
diese richtung möchte die partei nicht
warum verteidigen sie denn jetzt so ich
verteidige ihn gar nicht sondern ich
sage dass man dass das wählervotum muss
man akzeptieren und das wählervotum war
nun mal so wie es war
und wenn wenn wenn ich hier meinen
nachbarn zur linken sehe der
offensichtlich gewillt ist mit einer
partei die aus dem kommunismus kommt die
den sozialismus in deutschland wieder
einführen will
die verantwortlich war für den mauer
schießbefehl und für die toten an der
mauer und mit diesen dreien sind
teilweise bezeichnen als demokratisch
bleibt ja irre oder teil ihrer partei
und bei dem wasser was wir waren hinter
das was wir also dann bleiben sie doch
mal dabei ist christian hätte jemand wo
sie sagen das ist und in die afg wie ich
sie gerne hätte
aber der punkt ist doch es geht doch
nicht um die ecke sondern es geht nein
es geht nicht darum und wenn wenn es
tatsächlich und thüringen gehen sollte
dann erwarte ich auch die größe dass
jemand als person nicht im wege steht
wenn es zu koalition oder ich sage mal
auch zu einer tolerierung kommen kann
denn ich glaube auch dass es gerade der
fraktion in thüringen darum geht politik
für die thüringer zu machen und in die
zukunft schauen und das ist die frage
warum haben sie ihren eigenen kandidaten
nicht gewählt das ist auch so merkwürdig
weil man weil man natürlich ramelow
verhindern wollte weil ramelow thüringen
nicht gut getan hat schauen sie sich die
nackten zahlen an die arbeitslosenzahlen
sie nicht gesunken sind wir sind über
sie über eine million weiterhin
astrium thüringen hat 20 prozent der
bevölkerung verloren in den letzten
sechs jahren durchgesetzt worden 1 1
eric singer schauen sie mal also alles
was man sich vorgenommen hat hat nicht
funktioniert
thüringen hat mit die beste
wirtschaftliche machten sich die ganoven
frau herrmann wenn sie das hören diesen
streit ist das ein punkt wo man sagt da
hat sich jetzt etwas geändert
grundsätzlich mit diesem tag heute dass
wir jetzt auch in dieser form andere
schärfere auseinandersetzungen sie noch
nur stärkere abgrenzung zur afg oder er
auch der versuch dass man sagt okay wir
müssen ja irgendwie mehrheiten finden
also müssen wir auch vielleicht mit ihm
zusammenarbeiten
ja also ich meine das erste was wendet
man sich alle sofort erinnert haben als
sie gehört haben dass jetzt ein
ministerpräsident mit hilfe der afg an
die macht gekommen ist war ja dass genau
das 1930 auch schon mal passiert ist die
nsdap zuerst einmal in einem landtag in
thüringen kommt an die er warum er was
wisst warum quält liegt dieser vergleich
so auf der hand weil heuer die rechte
hand lykke li rui irrt leider wird nicht
konstruiert so das zweite ist nochmal
das seltsame ist also ein vorgang wie
heute haben wir noch nie erlebt
doch vor fünf jahren in thüringen nein
wir haben auch noch erlebt dass jemand
der nur fünf prozent bekommt der
ministerpräsident wird und wir haben
auch noch nie erlebt dass dieser mensch
der funde mit 5% ministerpräsident wird
sich erst im dritten wahlgang überhaupt
so bereitstellt und wir haben auch noch
nie erlebt dass eine partei ihren
eigenen kandidaten nicht wählt um
hintenrum einen anderen partei keinen
anderen kandidaten der erst im dritten
wahlgang auftaucht nach vorne zu
schieben
nichts davon hat es jemals gegeben und
das hat nichts mit demokratie zu tun das
ist hinterzimmer politik formulieren das
interessante ist doch noch sagen sie
ihre partei sagt immer in den
hinterzimmern wird gekommen was machen
sie in den bundestag
[Gelächter]
demokraten vorhaben von demokratien
alles was ich sage ist niemand hat so
viel immer gegen hinterzimmer kungeleien
polemisiert wie andy afd
und dann muss man feststellen keiner
hält den rekord wie die afg denn das was
sie heute abgezogen haben hat es in der
gesamten geschichte der bundesrepublik
noch nie gegeben und das war alles
hinterzimmer kungeleien und das muss man
jetzt mal fester okay wenn die auf die
das um getan hat wie sich jetzt sagen
herr polenz warum haben dann cdu und fdp
dieses spiel mitgemacht ja ich finde es
auch eine verantwortungslose
vorbereitung auf diese
ministerpräsidenten weil das man das
nicht vorausgesehen hat und nicht eine
strategie entwickelt hat die natürlich
schon hätte vermeiden können dass man
aktiv einen ministerpräsidenten mit welt
den mann nicht mitwählen will dass man
aber eben auch vermeidet das was wir
jetzt hier beklagen
und ich habe vorhin so ein bisschen
gezockt als es hieß erhöhte sah
umstritten in der fdp ist er nicht
umstritten
helgoland hat gesagt völker ist die
mitte und die seele der partei
aber ich habe er gesagt
doch kein unsicher gauland hatte ich
leider nicht gesagt die mitte und seele
der leyen hatte gemeint ja es hat keine
seele aber dass nach aber jetzt aber
jetzt noch mal wirklich zum kern
es geht jetzt um schadensbegrenzung
und ich kann nur ein mal von meiner
eigenen partei erwarten dass wir auch
genau analysieren wie es dazu kommen
konnte
und da wird man auf den punkt stoßen
dass das heutige ergebnis was die
parteivorsitzende was der bayerische
ministerpräsident server was unser
generalsekretär als einen traurigen tag
für deutschland und für thüringen
bezeichnet hat das ergebnis ist was ein
kleiner teil unserer partei die so
genannte werte union seit wochen und
monaten als das wunschergebnis
proklamiert hat das ist ein punkt mit
dem muss ich meine partei jetzt endlich
auseinandersetzen
gegen den willen
bundes passiert ist hält sich für falsch
aber es gibt eben diese sogenannte werte
union herr maßen als haupt
aushängeschild dieses dieser partei in
der partei sie organisiert sich ja mit
ortsvereinen mit landesverbänden und mit
einem mit einem bundesvorstand das hat
man sehr lange laufen lassen
es gab als gegenbewegung die union der
mitte dann war der appell die flügel
sollten sich auflösen union der mitte
hat das gemacht da war ich auch
engagiert haben gesagt okay die werte
union hat sich nicht darum gekümmert und
deren propagierung in den sozialen
medien überall war cdu sollen eigenen
kandidaten aufstellen und in kauf nehmen
dass die afd den mitwelt und jetzt das
ergebnis gut dann macht die cdu nicht
dann macht die es die fdp
und dann haben wir das was wir wollen
der große denkfehler ist bei all den
nicht zu erkennen dass die afg eben
keine konservative partei ist keine
bürgerliche partei ist soll eine
faschistische zahl sehen sie dass es
signale erzählen sie keinen unsinn und
sie sind keine konservativ bürgerliche
partei wir sind mittlerweile ein
linksgrünen sie ihre kanzlei in die
vertikale und sie genauso wenig dass
sich ihre tweets lesen polenz dann kann
ich muss ich eigentlich muss ich
eigentlich nichts dazu sagen schauen sie
sich gegen die afg hetzen sie hetzen
gegen die ft in einer art und weise dass
man nur den kopf schütteln kann
sie sollten sich eigentlich schämen und
freue mich dass ich so aussehe als
politiker das ist ein gern sie spalten
nämlich die gesellschaft nicht wir
wie geht man jetzt damit um also wenn es
neuwahlen wäre eine möglichkeit gäbe es
überhaupt eine andere wirklichkeit
benehmen würden sie sagen man kann man
muss irgendwie gucken dass spd grüne
linke versuchen irgendwie der erste
schritt der notwendig wer ist das jetzt
ein rücktritt gibt dass sie jetzt
gewählte ministerpräsident zurücktritt
und dann hat er sich immer gewählt hat
der mehrheit des vereins dann kann er
erst mal zurücktreten
das ist eine ganz freie entscheidung und
wenn er das so an bedauert dass er von
der afg gewählt wurde dann denke ich ist
das ein möglicher schritt und dann
können die demokratischen verteilen
überlegen wie sie vorgehen
ich glaube das wäre
eine vernünftige option ansonsten die
zweite handy heute gar nichts zu sehen
neuwahlen angenommen also dass er nicht
zurück die handlung recht tatsächlich
klügere alternative gewesen die wahl gar
nicht anzunehmen das wäre sicherlich
eine korrekte sache aber es ist eben
auch klar das ist der absprachen vorher
gab es sonst hätte es so überhaupt nicht
funktioniert mit diesem nicht wählen und
wählen der eigenen und dieser
geschlossenen block wahlen hat man ja
erkannt also insofern ich denke rückt
der erst die erste alternative die
option die zweite wären neuwahlen und
eine dieser beiden optionen müsste jetzt
überlegt werden das wäre glaube ich sehr
klug für türen das aber nicht passiert
was dann ja dann kann jetzt eine ganze
zeit lang regieren und da müssen wir
sehen dass er nur zwei alternativen hat
er kann sich bei der afg mehrheiten
holen oder bei der linken das haben alle
anderen ausgeschlossen hat eon von
sachen keine geben denn bei der linken
würde das nicht passieren muss er
überlegen aber von denen mit denen der
überhaupt nicht kooperieren will
als sich eine mehrheit verschafft für
gesetze in dem widerspruch hat sich
jetzt der ministerpräsident verstrickt
und aus dieser verstrickung nach nur er
sich befreien herr gates der ende
möglichkeit gab ja mal die idee mit
einer minderheitenregierung bestimmte
projekte gemeinsam zu machen
ericsson hätten sie dann noch sehen sie
eine möglichkeit wenn es neuwahlen gibt
dass sie sagen eigentlich oder wünschen
sie sich dass bodo ramelow wünschen sich
natürlich dass er gestärkt das können
sie sich das vorstellen oder wird das
jahr der wahlen gebe glaube ich dass
bodo ramelow oder eher gestärkt daraus
hervorgehen würde weil in einem ausmaß
der wille der mehrheit der thüringer und
thüringerin missachtet wurde
aber ich glaube es muss ein grundsatz
geben es kann keine fachliche und
sachliche zusammenarbeit mit der afg
geben
also hier haben wir einen fall dance
tatsächlich überhaupt in der geschichte
noch nicht gab und der hohe gefahren mit
sich bringt also wenn man weiß dass in
sachsen anhalt auch teile der cdu
überlegen mit der afg zusammenzugehen
dann ist es hochgefährlich also wer ein
bisschen geschichtsbewusst ist weißt
dass man da den anfängen wehren
muss und deswegen 23 prozent der
bevölkerung afd
das ist aber kein grund also 23 prozent
rang wende wenn wenn jemand eine
rassistische ausländerfeindliche und zum
teil nationalistische politiker nicht
machen dann müssen die anschauen oder
dann müssen wir anderen sagen damit
haben wir nichts zu tun da muss man
klare kante zeigen
es ist nicht so dass war erweist sich
übrigens auch in der geschichte unter
anderen länder das praktisch das
entgegenkommen praktisch gegen den was
solchen parteien zu irgendwas führte
steigt sie nur das macht sie hoffähig
deswegen muss man dort klare haltung
zeigen deswegen gehe ich davon aus dass
weder spd noch grüne noch linke sowieso
irgendwie auf das offene zusammenarbeit
kommen oder auf eine
minderheitsregierung in sachfragen ja
das wäre möglich gewesen mit mit anderen
parteien aber nicht mit der afd
und ich glaube man wird immer wieder
sprüche haben zwischen landesparteien
und bundes parteien des kids bei uns
gibt es bei jeder partei aber hier geht
es um eine grundsatzfrage es reicht
nicht aus wenn frau kramp karrenbauer
sagt es ist gegen unseren willen
passiert oder die fdp die muster sind
die muss jetzt eingreifen muss
klarstellen dass das dass ein
landesverband der cdu nicht so agieren
kann sondern irgendwie jede
glaubwürdigkeit verlieren aber auf der
anderen seite will die cdu natürlich
auch gerade von der afg wieder stimmen
zurückholen freimann wie können sie das
denn schaffen wäre das jetzt eine gute
chance oder ist das gerade dann
besonders schwer also ich glaube aber er
hat polens hat das ja schon gesagt was
für die gesamtpartei auf dem spiel steht
und das kann man nur wiederholen wenn
das jetzt durchgeht in thüringen und
wenn dann die cdu anfängt noch minister
zu stellen oder dann mit der afg
zusammen da irgendwelche gesetze
durchzubringen
dann heißt das auf bundesebene klares
signal für alle wähler wenn ich die cdu
wähle kann ich nicht am ende sicher sein
dass sie mit der afg im boot ist
und das bedeutet für die bundes-cdu dass
sie sehr stark an die grünen verlieren
wird das ist die gefahr das ist ja eine
gefahr die söder auch schon genauso auf
dem bundesparteitag der cdu
ausgesprochen hat so und deswegen ist
die cd aber polen ist ja wie gesagt
schon alles gesagt
der roller ist ja nur die muss die
bundes-cdu zentral daran aber passiert
sein so kann man machen was konkret und
das heißt es jetzt
mike mohring oder die cdu thüringen aus
dem den landesverband aus schlesien und
man kann so viel druck hinter den
kulissen ausüben nicht den richtigen
druck aus und investiert miteinander
geredet es witzig wenn sich die
parteigremien mit der frage zu
beschäftigen haben und man wird den
thüringer freundin deutlich machen
müssen dass ist jetzt um
schadensbegrenzung geht ja man hat ja
offensichtlich weisungen gegeben gebeten
aber man kann eben nicht befehlen man
kann nicht anordnen das geht von der
bundes partei gegenüber landesverbänden
zunächst einmal nicht und es geht jetzt
darum den schaden zu begrenzen und das
bedeutet die thüringische cdu muss
obwohl das natürlich ein schwerer
wahlkampf werden wird aber das hat sie
sich dann auch im stück weit selber
eingebrockt
für neuwahlen sein und dann wird man
sehen wie die ausgehen
im gegenteil ich glaube wenn die cdu
jetzt sichtbar
aus diesem fehler lernen kann sie
vielleicht sogar bei den wahlen sagen
also wir haben eine schmerzhafte
einsicht gehabt aber wir haben es
korrigiert und bitte ihr könnt euch auf
uns verlassen weil wir haben ja nachher
nicht mit der afg und wir sind da weiter
also das ist ja mal was man warum welche
chance wären neuwahlen für die afg also
zunächst mal muss ich sagen
die thüringer haben sich klar für eine
bürgerliche mehrheit entschieden dass
man sich aber nicht mehr ganz klar für
eine bürgerliche mehrheit entschieden
und neuwahlen werden bei den wählern und
wahrscheinlich genau das gegenteil
auslösen
dessen was sich herr polenz und andere
erhoffen ich glaube es wird die dfg noch
stärken
ja weil die wähler in thüringen ganz
eindeutig sehen dass hier irgendwelche
spielchen gespielt werden von der
cholera prozent von der acht prozent spd
von einer 5 prozent grüne licht werde
die spd ist das auch
die spd war mal eine volkspartei ist sie
nicht mehr mit ihren zwölf prozent der
bundesbürger nehmen was sie wird und sie
wird und sie wird wahrscheinlich
demnächst auch das schicksal erleiden
dass sie wahrscheinlich keine große
rolle mehr in deutsch verstehen wie das
war als ich 19 der ware zum bürgerlichen
parteien noch zählt sie zu den
bürgerlichen parteien
allerdings habe ich ein ganz großes ein
ganz großes problem damit wie man sich
hier den linken anbiedert einer partei
die eindeutig nicht auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes steht wenn man sich
anschaut wie tief die veraltete
verstrickung in die linksextreme szene
ist in die anti fahren ist ja wenn man
schaut wo sie herkommt welche wurzeln
sie hat dann kann man nur sagen wie kann
sich wie können sich demokratische
parteien die sich hier über die ard
echauffieren mit einer solchen partei
einlassen
und da kann ich nur sagen dass das
grenzt an prostitution man will dem
macht altmann will die freunde behalten
ja und offensichtlich sehr schwieriger
weil der cdu hat jetzt alles was
vollkommen egal das ist egal
die thüringer haben aber anders gewählt
und zwar an der wahlurne haben sie
gesagt
an der bar oder mit welchem recht
verlangen sie denn einen
ministerpräsidenten ramelow wenn rot rot
grüne 42 mandate hat und die
bürgerlichen parteien nahmen 48 mandate
aber so nach dem motto ja weil ihr das
wollen wir doch mal das sind schlechte
verlierer moment erwarten sie aber noch
mal um das klar zu machen
die linke hat 29 sitze die afg 22 also
der mehrheit hat die linke zu der sache
sagen wir diskutieren heute die
situation
die entstanden ist durch das verhalten
gegenüber der afg und ich verstehe dass
sie davon ablenken wollen und daraus
jetzt der diskussion über linkspartei
machen wollen es ist und deshalb möchte
ich nur sagen die cdu hat sich auch
positioniert im verhältnis zur
linkspartei
indem sie gesagt hat wir können mit
dieser partei nicht koalieren aber aus
anderen gründen
hierbei wir über ein anderes thema reden
und ich will ihnen jetzt sagen dass für
uns der grund und das kann man anders
sehen aber so siehts meine partei und so
sehe ich es auch
nach wie vor darin liegt dass eine ein
bemühen der linken um eine aussöhnung
mit den opfern der sed herrschaft nicht
die entschuldigung erklärung und nicht
den historischen kommission das weiß
dass das alles gegeben aber ich vermisse
auch persönlich eine ein bemühen ein
aktives bemühen um aussöhnung mit den
opfern der sed herrschaft und solange
das nicht passiert können wir über die
vielen politischen fragen die uns
grundsätzlich trennen in der
wirtschaftspolitik in der außenpolitik
und wo auch immer nicht so miteinander
reden wie man sozusagen unter gleichen
redet aber ich will heute bewusst dieses
thema weil das nicht ansteht wir wollten
ein ramelow nicht wählen wir haben ihn
nicht gewählt aber wenn sie jetzt im
nach würden sie aber es war doch ein
fehler war herr ramelow jemand ist von
den linken wo sie sagen der ist sehr
stark ich ja ich habe das für vernünftig
gefunden dass die cdu sagt okay dann
wird jetzt dieses modell einer projekt
regierung gemacht dafür haben diejenigen
dafür haben diejenigen die verantwortung
die diese minderheitsregierung bilden
wollen wir werden sehen was wir da
sachlich durchsetzen können und man
bemüht sich dann sozusagen von fall zu
fall wie es geht ob es lange ereignete
weiß ich auch nicht aber das wäre ein
gangbarer weg gewesen mit dem
wahlergebnis umzugehen
eric single hätte sich die linke im
nachhinein gibt so punkte sagen da
hätten wir uns vielleicht anders
verhalten können damit wir da auch
einfach eine andere mehrheit hätten und
auch vielleicht koalitionsfähig mit der
cdu gewesen wären naja erstmal muss ich
sagen dass ich ganz glücklich darüber
wenn das uns die afg hier so angreift
weil in der tat fühle ich mich in der
rolle wohl dass wir die entschiedensten
gegner dieser partei sind das zweite ist
das ist natürlich absurd hier von
demokratie zu reden
demokratie wäre wenn vorher offen gelegt
wird was die parteien machen ja und das
hat die linke gemacht er hat immer
gesagt wir wollen praktisch rot-rot-grün
fortsetzen sie hat ein klares programm
gemacht sein koalitionsvertrag dafür
ausgehandelt die cdu hat gesagt wir
lassen uns nicht von der afg wählen
und die fdp hat es im übrigen auch
gesagt sie haben das gegenteil jetzt
gemacht und das hat nichts mit
transparenz und demokratie zu tun
genauso wenig wie man den eigenen
kandidaten nicht gewählt
ich weiß nicht ob wir da was falsch
gemacht haben natürlich hätten wir
lieber eine klare mehrheit gehabt aber
es war doch klar dass wenn sowohl cdu
wie fdp sagen wir lassen uns nicht von
der fdp ihren oder arbeiten mit ihr
zusammen muss man den weg nach
minderheitsregierung suchen
das war von uns immer transparent und
wir haben dann ein programm vorgelegt
und dem kann man sich abarbeiten als
hätte die option gegeben zu sagen cdu
hätte gar nicht den ramelow wählen
brauchen
das erwarte ich auch gar nicht ehrlich
gesagt ich weiß auch gar nicht ob das
gut für uns ist
aber ausgereicht wenn sich viele leute
enthalten hätten oder sehen einen
eigenen kandidaten aufgestellt es war
für die cdu hat sich viel ärger ersparen
können sie werden jetzt gespalten seien
ja ich hab das cdu präsidium hat
einstimmig beschlossen die empfehlung
für neuwahlen zu geben ja ja das jahr
richtig aber in thüringen hat er der
mohring der meine fans zurückgeben muss
ja hatten die cdu in eine unmögliche
situation gebracht jemand es ist nicht
mein problem
aber ich meine das ist keine geradlinige
politik ja auch eine ganz falsche der
der spd geht es in thüringen gar nicht
gut acht prozent hat sie bekommen bei
der letzten bei dieser wahl eben wenn es
jetzt neue ware gäbe herr binding mit
welcher konsequenz geben würden sie ihn
in einen wahlkampf der mosel wo würden
die sich eigentlich positionieren meinen
in brandenburg sachsen und thüringen
haben wir gesehen wer die wahlen gewinnt
immer die die in der regierungsfraktion
die mehrheit stellen also das war in
allen drei wahlen so ähnlich und ich
muss ja auch respektieren dass die
wähler zu 60% bodo ramelow als einen
guten ministerpräsident in ihrem land
ansehen und gleichwohl denke ich dass
nach der situation die jetzt eingetreten
ist neuwahlen gut sind
ich glaube auch wenn die leute merken
dass das eine die wahl ist und die
zweite frage ist wie gehen eigentlich
die parteien dann im parlament damit um
und wenn tricksen und täuschen nach
vorne gestellt wird glaube ich merkt der
wähler
was passiert im parlament das habe ich
nicht gewollt also trickser und täuscher
wollte ich nicht wählen deshalb glaube
ich auch dass die wähler durchaus noch
mal überlegen wen sie wählen deshalb bin
ich da durchaus optimistisch in dieser
ablenker historisch wer wessen
nachfolger ist und so ich glaube das
führt heute nicht weiter wenn wir da in
die tiefen schauen dann merkt man sehr
viele parallelen mit einer vergangenheit
auf die wir uns nicht mehr gerne berufen
wollen aber die sich jetzt fortsetzt und
deshalb glaube ich dass es gut ist
neuwahlen auszuschreiben
das ist natürlich eine ganz schwache
position die ihre die bundes der bundes
spd geht es nicht gut in die runde nicht
geht dann stehen deshalb arbeiten wir
daran das zu verbessern
na gut mal sehen also welche
möglichkeiten oder wenn es jetzt neue
gelbe frau hamann
was bedeutet das schauen wir doch noch
mal auf das hier in berlin wir haben
eine große koalitionen wir haben eine
schwache spd
was könnte das für ein signal dann für
diese große koalition geben
also ich glaube die frage ist jetzt und
die ist ja wirklich spannend kann sich
die bundes cdu spricht kann sich angela
merkel gegen thüringen durchsetzen also
sozusagen der bürgerkrieg rampe bauen
oder annegret kampagne aber letztlich
müssen alle helfen und letztlich wenn
jetzt annegret kramp karrenbauer sich
gegen die thüringer cdu nicht
durchsetzen kann dann ist merkel fällig
weil dann ist ja klar nein man ist ja
klar dass die kanzlerin keinerlei basis
mehr in der partei hat also das würde
dann so ein problem wurde nicht bei
annegret kramp karrenbauer alleine
landen kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
und wie herr polenz ja schon dargestellt
hat und das muss man die ernst nehmen
und so klar habe ich das noch nie gehört
ist ja dass in der partei in der cdu
praktischen bürgerkrieg herrscht
zwischen der wert der union und den rest
der partei und die dieser krieg oder
dieser auseinandersetzung muss es ja
nicht gleich mit kampf und kabeln
beschreiben wird jetzt am beispiel
thüringen entschieden und wenn thüringen
weitermachen kann wie bisher dann
bedeutet das dass die werte union in der
cdu das sagen hat und das wäre eine
erhält das wäre ein erdbeben für ganz
deutschland oder zur afg gehen könnte ja
oder zu gehen und wenn wenn die cdu das
macht dann ist der nächste kanzler ein
grüner so und deswegen wird die werte
union sich nicht durchsetzen
das alles spielt sich jetzt in kleinen
bundesland thüringen ab also das ist
richtig weil man aber sagen es könnte
aber auch sein dass sind viele wähler
die jetzt sagen hör die werte union noch
eher wer die cdu wählen würden ja nicht
die afd
dann sagen die dann gehen wir jedoch zur
afd die cdu muss hier muss hier für
klarheit sorgen
und sie hat einen freund gefragt wie
wollen wir den wähler zurückgewinnen die
jetzt beispielsweise auch mal afd
gewählt haben wir gewinnen sie nicht
dadurch zurück dass wir der spitze
hinterherlaufen wir gewinnen sie nicht
dadurch zurück dass wir uns möglichst
nah an die afg heran schmeißen sondern
im gegenteil wir brauchen eine
doppelstrategie auf der einen seite
deutlich machen wie tief und breiter
graben ist der uns von der afg trend
sonst wissen sich ja gar nicht warum so
etwas falsch gemacht haben als wähler
und zum anderen auf die fragen eingehen
auf die sorgen eingehen auf die ängste
eingehen die die afg schürt von denen
die afg lebt und wo die cdu sich bemühen
muss lösungen zu finden die den menschen
diese sorgen nimmt uns ein allgemeines
generalsekretär jack sagt das ist ein
nazi ist hilft das dann oder ist das nie
gefahren ist ist erstmal eine richtige
bezeichnung und aber trennen wollen sie
nicht ich bin ich bin selber spalten
gerichtlich was sehen sie es sein dass
sie sind ich habe sehr aus der
geschichte gelernt die notwendiges ist
dass demokraten zusammen stehen und in
der tat extremisten abspalten wenn die
kommunisten die waren alle kaputt
gemacht ich bin für jede diskussion
wenn ihr mal zu der diskussion
eingeladen werden gemeinsam dann könne
über die frage reden wie heißt es mit
der linkspartei im augenblick jetzt um
die frage wie hältst du es mit der
faschistischen afd
und da habe ich klar meine position
gesagt
dann das ist absoluter unsinn mit der
faschistischen afd
weil sie wissen das ganz genau sie
versuchen hier immer wieder eine relativ
zu bedienen das einfach nicht stimmt ja
weil sie glauben sie könnten dadurch
wieder wähler für sich zurück zu
gewinnen dabei aber schauen sie mal zu
schauen sie doch mal schauen sie doch
mal auf die bundes cdu
die permanent verliert die bo ist die
cdu mittlerweile bei 21 oder 22
das kann ich das ich habe meine danke
weit mehr wähler verlieren
warum haben sie sich dann aber gegen ein
hacker gestellt sie haben gesagt ich
weil ich nicht gut das war wieder ein
aussagen weil ich mit bestimmten
aussagen von herrn röcken nicht
einverstanden bin
das habe ich immer wieder gesagt ich
hab' ich mache eine andere politik aber
letzten endes machen wie afd politik und
hacker hat sich herr höcker hat sich
aber in diesem in dieser situation in
thüringen hat er sich meines erachtens
richtig verhalten
er hat dem wählerwillen hat er
nachgegeben und der wählerwille sagt
eindeutig soll eine bürgerliche mehrheit
geben und keine links war grüne mehrheit
sie haben 42 mandate in thüringen und
glauben den ministerpräsidenten stellen
zu können
obwohl die oppositionspartei ehemaligen
oppositionsparteien 48 man da was ist
das denn für ein nach oben gegangen ist
hat der manager aber sie wollten was ist
das für eine ganz so lang sein dass man
schlafen ich war schon mal
ministerpräsidenten das muss ich mir das
nochmal die frage sie haben jetzt einen
ministerpräsidenten gewählt der fünf
prozent ist das demokratisch ist dass
der welt ausdruck des wählerwillens der
wählerwille ist heute im parlament
umgesetzt worden und die und die
bürgerlichen parteien die bürgerlichen
parteien haben herrn kemmerich gewählt
das muss man einfach akzeptieren dass es
so ich das ist demokratie das will ich
sehe deutlich sagen aber wahrscheinlich
muss man in demokratie noch beibringen
eines abschieden thüringischen
wählerinnen und wähler die der cdu ihre
stimme gegeben haben waren sich sicher
dass diese stimmabgabe nicht zu
irgendeinem wachsenden einfluss der afg
führen würde
und diese jetzt zum teil oder vielleicht
komplett enttäuschte erwartungen
die muss die cdu in thüringen und die
muss die cdu bundesweit korrigieren weil
sonst haben wir an einer existenziellen
frage von meiner partei ein
riesenproblem und macht dieses ergebnis
heute auch deutlich dass wir doch noch
einen großen unterschied zwischen ost
und west haben in der in der beurteilung
weil im westen des landes sind solche 48
68 prozent der befragten dafür dass es
keine zusammenarbeit zwischen cdu und
fdp gibt und im osten sind 2 46 prozent
ist da noch ein unterschied ja dann mag
es unterschiede geben die afg es da in
der regel im osten etwas stärker aber
ich glaube in der haltung darf es keinen
unterschied geben und ich bin im übrigen
nicht dafür jetzt die fdp aus der
verantwortung zu lassen also ich meine
der fdp dieses ganze spiel mit
inszeniert und es war eine inszenierung
also das war jetzt nicht auszusehen
irgendwie passiert sonst wären die
abstimmungsergebnisse nicht erklärbar
ich finde eine partei die sich liberal
nennt und praktisch hier auch nochmal
hinter äußerungen des
ministerpräsidenten vorher sich von
rechten wählen lässt deshalb auch mit
liberal nichts zu tun und ich finde da
müssen wie ihr verhältnis klären da also
dass sie hat gesagt er arbeitet nicht
mit denen zusammen noch mal wissen will
oder in der regierung zustande
eingeschaltet haben wir haben versucht
jemand von der fdp zu kommen zu bekommen
das ist leider nicht hat es hat nicht
funktioniert weil wir diese sendung
allem auch kurzfristig ins programm
genommen haben ich bedanke mich für die
diskussion bedanke mich bei ihnen für
das zusammen schauen und ich denke wir
dass thüringen wahlergebnis heute der
ministerpräsident war wurde so eine
ganze weile beschäftigen auch in berlin
schöner abend
[Musik]